morel bonjour merci d'être en direct sur
rt france un remaniement je cite de
grande ampleur selon l'entourage des
manuels macron de nouveaux talents
capables d'incarner le virage écologique
et l'urgence de la situation économique
s est un désaveu officiel des ministres
actuels à votre avis de tous mais dans
un certain nombre
on sait qu'il ya des ministres qui vont
probablement rester le parc de jean
michel blanquer parle de jean yves le
drian aux affaires étrangères ou parle
également de bruno le maire alors il
peut y avoir éventuellement les
surprises du point de vue de leurs
portefeuilles et notamment son périmètre
mais on a quelques têtes structurel de
l'exécutif qui ne devrait pas être
désavoué qu'en revanche on sait qu'il ya
des ministères qui aujourd'hui pose
problème pense notamment à l'intérieur
en pal site et donc pour toutes ces
raisons là parmi les grands ministères
régaliens structure ou du nouveau
gouvernement
il va en effet y avoir des mouvements
est ce que ce sera vraiment des
surprises par rapport à des noms qui
étaient entendus et attendu depuis
quelques mois
ça c'est la grande question est de toute
façon ça marquera la fin de quinquennat
d'autant que ce quinquennat et point de
vue purement du temps politique avec la
campagne qui passe déclenché en janvier
il n'est pas loin d'être terminée en
réalité de quelque chose mais non pour
s'accélérer très vite économie et
écologie sont les priorités affichées du
locataire de l'elysée à votre avis ah
que c'est à dire que on est à la veille
d'une crise économique dont je crois on
a du mal encore à mesurer l'ampleur donc
le naughton social va être extrêmement
compliqué emmanuel macron on a
conscience il a conscience également du
kippour est maintenant d'agenda
parlementaire à partir de à partir de
septembre donc tout ça fait que sur ces
points là qui sont importants pour son
électorat mais qui au delà sont
nécessaires que le pays tienne durant
cette fin de quinquennat va falloir
aller très vite et très rapidement
efficace il ya d'autres priorités qui
ont été mis en exergue par le nouveau
premier ministre
on voit notamment que l'accent sur le
régalien sur lequel
emmanuel macron pour l'instant on
n'avait pas été extrêmement fort doté
effet avec un retour notamment de la
thématique de la laïcité donc pour
emmanuel macron très clairement il faut
camper aujourd'hui la figure du chef de
l'état et il faut également parce qu'on
n'est jamais loin d'une réflexion un peu
politicienne et de cuisine électorale
il faut surtout retenir l'électorat de
centre-droit dont on a dû aux
municipales qui ne pouvait très bien
revenir un beau salaire critiquent le
discours politique jean castex qui
devait avoir lieu en milieu de semaine
d'affilée va finalement devoir attendre
un petit peu on sait qu'il prendra
finalement la parole après emmanuel
macron qui va s'exprimer à l'occasion du
14 juillet ce que emmanuel macron
dessinera lors de feux discours on va
dire le cadre mais aussi les directions
pour la fin de son mandat et puis
finalement jean castex devra exécuter
tout simplement
c'est en grande partie le cas alors si
vous voulez c'est le cas sous la vème
république hors cohabitation mais là on
atteint un degré de concentration des
pouvoirs dans les mains du président de
la république avec notamment une forme
d' aspirations d'une partie du pouvoir
qui se trouve à matignon qui est tout de
même assez important
ça passe par cette affaire de discours
mais ça passe surtout par la nomination
du directeur de cabinet nicolas revel du
chef de cabinet medias côte qui en fait
ou vont encadrer jean castex est donc là
on voit très clairement que le pouvoir
qu'ils se trouvent
si on prend la situation administrative
de la france
le pouvoir du point de vue de
l'administration au pouvoir
réglementaire
le secrétariat jeune maman tout ça se
tient à matignon à l'elysée vous avez un
pouvoir politique mais du point de vue
du fonctionnement de l'état le poids il
est à matignon il y as avec la
nomination de jean castex et plus encore
avec la nomination de son entourage
avec cette affaire de chronologie des
discours une volonté d' emmanuel macron
devrais m'en tenir
mettre la main sur le pouvoir au sein de
l'état estime justement cette hyper
pouvoir d' emmanuel macron peut-il être
à double tranchant pour la fin du
quinquennat
c'est probable pour plusieurs raisons
parce que il n'ya pas deux il ya
difficilement un premier ministre
paratonnerre en moins depuis quinquennat
le premier ministre ne prend pas les
coûts à la place du président de la
république le président de la république
est considéré comme étant comptable de
la politique menée est donc c'est ça qui
énerve un petit peu emmanuel macron
c'est à dire qu'il a l'impression que le
parti du pouvoir d'achat mais quand le
compte de ce qui se passe et là tu sais
le gac après vous aviez tout de même
avec edouard philippe une forme de
complémentarité c'est à dire que edouard
philippe permettait notamment de pomper
l'électorat de centre-droit d'incarner
une forme comme jadis françois fillon de
continuité de calme de structures au
sein de l'état alors que emmanuel macron
était plus dans une image disruptif qui
pouvait éventuellement plérin
l'électorat centrisme qui peut également
effrayé
une partie de cet électorat et
l'électorat de centre droit est ce que
le fait d'avoir un premier ministre
probablement voulu effacer dans un rôle
plus secondaire que celui qui avait
assumé ces dernières années lors
philippe va permettre de tenir cet
électorat là ça c'est un pari qu'a fait
emmanuel macron c'est un pari qui n'est
pas gagné d'autant que dans l'électorat
et la romaine et une partie l'électorat
lr edouard philippe était extrêmement
populaire
l'entente n'a pas d' enquêtes d'opinion
mais il n'est pas dit que cet électorat
pardonne emmanuel macron le débarquement
de chine l'ancien premier ministre
merci beaucoup benjamin morel d'avoir
réagi sur d'autres que vous êtes docteur
en science politique et maître de
conférences à l'université paris 2